- The biggest problem is, you're right,
you're climbing up a
hill, that isn't gonna
be valuable when you get there.
- Right, right.
- It's super not interesting to eat shit
for the next seven years, get there,
and be like, (makes cartoon noise).
That's exactly what's gonna happen.
(upbeat music)
(happy chiming)
- How are you, Steve?
- Great, and yourself?
- Really good.
Yeah, anywhere.
Don't worry about them, the vlog is easy.
Did you guys meet Nate?
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
So tell me what you guys are up to.
- Uh, well I'll try to be
as concise as possible,
but obviously I retired three years ago--
- That goes fast, man.
- Yeah, and it took me two years
to kind of find balance again, in my life.
- To like just decompress from that?
- Yeah, I can't sit still.
I have a production company,
and we've directed a 30 for 30,
we've done a bunch of digital content,
we are doing stuff in
filming television and--
- [Man] Sorry, are you Steve Nash?
- Yes.
(group squeals)
- Went through a soccer game, actually.
- [Host] You met at a soccer game.
- I've been in LA for a year.
We played football together.
- But anyways, so, we're doing
film and television stuff,
and trying to figure out like,
what is it we really wanna do,
and we've slowly started
to figure that out,
but at the same time, filming television,
you're going up against the Titans,
guys who have been doing it for 30 years,
there's ways to make in growings,
but there's just such an upside
to building something digital.
- Yeah, I mean, the biggest problem
is you're right, you're climbing up a hill
that isn't gonna be
valuable when you get there.
- Right.
- It's super not interesting to eat shit
for the next seven years, get there,
and be like (makes cartoon noise).
That's exactly what's gonna happen.
So you're like okay, let's not do that.
- And then at the same time,
I've never really been one that like,
like there was a part of me that's like,
I maybe will just disappear,
and not be heard from again and my life.
Be with my kids, and do all the things
that I wanna do, and just
kind of get away from it.
But then I realized--
- That's just not who you are.
- I enjoy life.
- You're also young as shit.
- I like traveling, I think
I do have something to say.
So I'm trying to find my voice
in a way that we can be in control of it,
we can be impactful,
transformative, sports content.
Has started to get exciting for me,
and then we've started to take
a step filming some stuff,
and conceiving some stuff,
and so, as I think I've heard you say,
to learn cheaply, earn the way.
So, I think that's right now,
is we're trying to fill a platform,
that initially starts around my life,
you know, whether it's vlogs, or podcasts,
or little series that we conceive of,
but that hopefully, it starts to bring
in other athletes and people.
- Yeah, man, yes.
Yeah, build the leverage, and then decide
where you wanna put all that attention,
whether it's through something like,
your version of the ESPN bar
stool, or Players Tribune,
mixed with TED, and I think you if you can
spend a year, 18 months,
building up your personal brand,
creating content exactly how you said it,
whether the vlog and the podcast
are the main pillars, or
the podcast, or the vlog,
surround it with other stuff,
and then really read the tea leaves
and see who's reaching
out to you from your
first chapter of your life,
who's emerging and interested
in this new chapter.
It's funny, learn cheaply, must
make mistakes at low costs,
but more importantly,
gather enormous amounts
of quant and qual feedback,
and the other thing is also,
recognizing in 24 months,
there may be a slight
spin on it that you don't know yet,
or taste yet, or it's
literally one story, from one--
You know?
- Yeah.
- One former teammate, or somebody else,
or a guy or a kid on the street
that stops you, that could end up becoming
the anchor of the framework.
So the thing with the
vlog, that I would tell you
is super important to me,
as the first thing about this meeting,
you need to go fast,
there are still not famous
people really vlogging.
- Right, so before it catches on--
- Yeah, the same reason Ashton won
so big on twitter, the same
reason Khalid won on Snapchat,
there's not a lot of,
I mean, I don't know.
Gavin, I'm so busy, but I don't feel
like there's no athlete of your caliber
that I can think of that
is vlogging, for real.
- [Man] Yeah, bits of
clips come out on internet,
and stuff like that, but--
- Yeah, I mean, I'm super
close with Maverick,
and all that, but that's
not him on YouTube
with no subscribers at first,
being like hey, like really doing it.
That's fucking crazy, and then again,
all these characters--
When you're actually famous,
and you actually played basketball,
I mean like, half the
vloggers that are doing well,
I'm talking like the Paul Brothers,
and all these crazy
characters that I know,
them sitting there being like,
"Is Steve Nash actually
vlogging on YouTube?"
Followed by, "Holy shit,
let's reach out to him,
"and do like a 3-point
contest in my back yard."
Is like, insane.
Especially in LA, they're all,
like people overthink it,
they think if the first
episode isn't right,
you can't mess up.
- Go on to the next, this
new cycle's so (mumbles).
- Like, the ideal tweet is like,
Holy shit, I listened to
Steve Nash's first podcast,
it sucked, episode 17 with Antoine Walker,
how he lost all his money, is insane.
You can't lose.
- Yeah.
- The only way you can
lose is by not recognizing
how few people that look
like you have done it,
and then letting two of them,
I mean, everybody's
having this conversation.
Like, everybody kinda
knows something's going on.
- It's who gets out there first,
and yeah, you're right, I mean,
I think we--
It's not a box set, right?
It's not gonna go like in a library,
you want to connect with an audience,
and keep connecting with them,
and learn to connect better,
and keeping on to them.
- This is not a game won by the way
Star wars is won, it's
not special affects,
it's just not, it's not
the game we're playing.
What's cool about it is,
if you do this game
right, you have unlimited
ability to do Star Wars, if you want.
- Right.
- Like true family, I
was pumped when you said,
can I bring my guy?
I'm like perfect, I'm bringing Nate.
This is not a joke, at some
point in the last 18 months
or so, or two years
ago, or three years ago,
Nate's like, "There's three
people I need you to become
"friends with, Steve Nash, John
Mayor, and Phil Nickelson."
And this is not a joke, I
become friends with all three
this year.
It was the craziest.
Hold on.
- Sweet, thanks.
(people talking over one another)
- [Man] Safe travels, everybody.
- [Host] Have a great holiday, man.
- [Man] Bye, guys!
- Bye, take care!
Great meeting with Steve Nash,
what a great fuckin' dude.
Love meeting like, dudes that are awesome.
Getting towards the end of the year vlog,
super excited to see what
the team does for you guys
in these two weeks that I'm away,
you got stuff (mumbles)?
Got some stuff, just wrapping up the year,
getting a bunch of
contracts signed for 2018,
VaynerMedia's looking
real, real, real good.
Coming out the gate hard.
With a new book on the
30th, excited about that.
Got a bunch of conferences, agent 20/21,
big evenT in Houston, Super Bowl,
Vayner Sports Party, couple weeks later,
NBA all-star weekend, Vayner Sports Party,
got two new sneakers coming out,
the 003, 004, but
predominantly 96% Vayner X,
pure wow, Vayner Media,
real hard core focus
for me next year.
Excited about it.
Genuinely excited about next year, man.
(spits)
Show that part, I wanna
hear all the comments.
(grunts)
So here's what we're gonna
have to figure out, right?
Even though, I feel the way about you
that I felt with my wife, I'm gonna need
a couple of months of us jamming, right?
I also wanna know them a little bit.
So what we need to think about is,
I hear you loud and clear,
and I love the way
you're talking about it,
I need to figure out the vibes.
We need to figure out how,
there's so much good here,
right, there's so many
ways to slice this.
I need to be thoughtful of like,
I gotta feel comfortable
and then I can go fast,
you know what I mean?
(upbeat music)
- Ah, how you doing man?
- Good, brother, how are you?
- Feeling okay?
- I feel amazing, you
look insane, brother.
I mean, I see it online, but--
to see it in person makes
me so fuckin' happy.
- Man, just like, your words resonated
so much with me, just cause,
I mean, I've always like--
It's like you have disciples.
- I'm aware.
A funny thing happens
when you speak the truth.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
- You know?
- When you speak the
truth with no expectation,
or wants in return, and
mine's not like religious,
or altruistic, mine's more predicated
on my ability to get mine,
and being brought up in a way that,
my mom and I were talking
about this the other day,
of just like, I'm so similar
to my mom in a lot of ways,
and I got certain things of my dad,
and that's how I become me,
we don't want anything from anybody,
everything's our fault,
we're very insular,
um, I know, man.
- Mm-hm.
- The best part is when
you get to interact
with somebody you know, like,
there's millions of people
eventually I'll never know,
but to your point of eight years,
it's like, I was thinking about it today,
when we were like, we're
gonna make it happen.
Just thinking about all
the silly conversations
through the years,
building mix-tapes, and--
- Travis Porter--
- Travis Porter,
I always think about those stories.
You know?
And then just watching your whole like,
when you started running,
like one of those videos
really caught me, when
you were like ready to go,
and now you look, I mean,
people don't even recognize you,
I'm sure.
Like, you roll up on
people, they're like, what?
(laughs)
Right?
- Yeah, I almost didn't recognize you
when you walked through the main lobby.
And I saw you like a month ago,
like he's really training.
- When I was young,
like, I always wanted to be an athlete,
that was like my core,
true, rolled in truth.
Like, I'm gonna be an athlete.
But then I was always the big kid.
And like, I loved basketball,
and church versus skins, as a kid,
like I'd have to drop down like,
if they picked skins, I'm
gonna be able to play,
and then the pool never took my--
- Sure.
- So I needed something to be good at,
growing up, so, it's like when you want
girls to like you, you've
gotta have something
that you, and, um, I was like,
I'm gonna be in business.
Like, I'm CEO Charlie, like young age,
I'm CEO Charlie, and, at that early age,
I varied what I truly wanted to be,
and I did business, and I got good at it.
And as the business grew,
you know, like, I grew.
(laughs)
And it's got up over,
you know, 300 pounds,
and this guy Cameron,
he came into my life, and
he was the most amazing man.
He said I like see something in you,
but like, he was like,
you can't diet anymore,
because I can tell your brain is fried
from always doing diets,
he said we're gonna run,
so we did three marathons,
and from the first
marathon to third marathon,
I gained weight.
- Really?
- Yes, cause I was a binge eater,
like I would run, and
I could run 26.2 miles,
but then, I'd crack, and I'd
eat 10,000 calories in a night.
I knew something was wrong,
but I didn't know what
was wrong, and one day,
I woke up and the room
just started spinning.
And this is when he was doing
the Dab and stand sweaters,
they were like killing the whole game.
- Yeah, like, I wake up--
- Right, you're at the
top of your business game.
- Never sad, never, wake
up, room is spinning,
I'm like oh, this isn't good.
And then I got outta bed,
went to pick up the shoes,
passed out.
- Woke up where?
- On the floor!
- But you woke up there?
Not in a hospital or anything?
- No, no, no.
- And?
- Went to the doctor,
brain tumor wrapped around
left optic nerve, coronary artery,
it could start corroding
the top of my spinal cord.
At that point, it's
like, when you gave me,
like my secret sword to go slay my dragon.
Like, I'm like, I'm
gonna change everything.
This is something lasting.
I'm gonna change everything.
And I knew everything had to change,
and I left my company, and
said I'm gonna do an Iron Man.
And I said, I'm gonna reverse
the brain tumor naturally,
because I'm not doing chemo,
and this medication that
the doctors have me on,
affects your heart valves,
that's when I said,
I'm gonna do an Iron Man,
and I just started going.
I went vegan, plant-based,
and reversing it naturally,
like my brain tumor's shrinking
because of the food I eat.
- I get it, brother.
I believe in that shit.
In a real fuckin' way.
- When I'm on my bike rides,
like, I did 112 mile bike
ride from Atlanta to Alabama,
and back, and I got through,
I think like 37 episodes of Daily V.
Like, when I say like,
I had to change everything
I was consuming.
Not just food, but like what you consume.
Literally, it's like, when I
say you gave me that sword,
to slay my dragon, I'm taking
the biggest risk of my life,
like, when I left my
company, this was scary.
- Hell yeah, it's scary.
Cause it's your truth.
- Talk about eating dirt,
millionaire, now I live
with four roommates.
Because I know, I'm smart
enough to know like,
okay, where I'm going,
I wanna be an athlete,
that's not just like clear,
I'm a good businessman, I've always been
a good businessman, but my dream,
that eight year old truth,
before I put all this
society stuff on me, this mask,
I wanna be an athlete.
So I'm eating dirt, I know I'm gonna die,
now I'm gonna live, like damn.
(laughs)
Thank you, man.
I need to confirm something with you.
- Go ahead.
- So, my friends, you
know, there's some people
that like you, and some
people who don't, right?
- Oh me, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
- And I wanna know if this is right?
- Go ahead.
- True or false, for me to
speak on your behalf to people.
And they're like, man, is he happy?
- And I'm like, you know what,
this is my theory on Gary.
My grandparents were
immigrants from Lebanon.
And they had your mentality, not success,
but mentality, like immigrants,
like they're not worried
about, they are happy.
In their mission.
- Oh, so the questions of the
friends, or acquaintances is,
am I happy because I'm always working?
- Like I think that is
what makes you happy,
because I know that's what
made my grandparents happy,
they weren't worried about "happiness"--
- I'm absolutely, like, that
makes a lot of sense to me,
that's a valid question for people
that value other things, it's values.
Like, nothing makes me
happier than building.
- Mm-hmm.
- Nothing makes me happier than building,
in a way that also builds
up people along the way,
as I'm building.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I love working.
Like, I get it.
My big thing is that,
I think people need to be
smart about what they say,
you know?
Like, to me, the person that's
far more unhappy than I am,
is the one that says, that their CEO,
or they're hustling and they're not.
I think anybody is happy when they're
living their truth,
including the verse of me.
I think the people that I
notice that are most happy,
that remind me of me, are actually people
that aren't working that much.
That have found their work/life balance.
I grew up in a very lower/middle-class,
I have very interesting
point of reference,
which is, the happiest
person I saw growing up,
were my parents who worked like dogs,
both my mom in the house,
my dad outside, and random
people that were like
friends' parents that
were making 47k a year,
and they just liked drinking Budweiser
and watching the game, and
like kept it simple as fuck.
I think people find happiness
in extremes, I really do.
I think when you're half pregnant,
you're stuck, that's why
making a hundred, 10,000 a year
scares me, like it feels middle.
- Yeah, I'd also say, you know,
Gary has a great family, he has two kids,
and he loves football, so even to answer
a few of your questions, there
are things that aren't worth,
you know what I mean?
They're like, it's like a big
part of your life, you know?
- Honestly, I'm just
happy people are talking.
- Well yeah, if you're successful,
people are gonna say that stuff.
- No, listen, very few
people come at me with real
heat or anger, if they do,
they're just in a bad place,
listen, I'm working much
harder than most people.
That's just the truth.
And I think that fucks with people,
especially when I started the vlog,
and there became no debate.
But I did that on purpose,
cause I know there's a lot of people,
honestly, there's a lot of immigrants
who can outwork the competition.
Or, where the fuck are you two from?
You don't need to be an immigrant,
like there's a lot of people that live
like immigrants that are born here,
like, yeah, I think I mean for me,
brother, I'm living my truth, you know?
Honestly, I'm most unhappy when I'm
doing the most normal shit.
(man mumbling in background)
- I'm only happy in my extremes.
Just living your truth, man.
Right?
But the fact that you
tapped into yourself,
and executed, you know how rare that is?
- Thank you, man.
- People are scared to live their truth.
Because they're worried about
all the other variables.
That's why your world is so extreme,
you went so hardcore both ways.
It's good to see you, man.
- Thank you, man, thank you for time, too.
- Of course, man.
(upbeat music)